odds are this weekend one of your
favorite streamers
got nailed with a copyright strike
because twitch streamers are being
bombarded right now with strikes for
playing music
they just don't have the rights to i
don't know about you guys
but my twitter timeline was flooded with
streamers trying to delete their vods
as fast as possible so what's happening
and how did we get here let me explain
that for you
[Music]
alright so if you like our content here
on youtube i urge you to head over to
twitch.tv
thescore esports and give us a follow on
twitch every week we're coming at you
with multiple live streams with
all the personalities you love on the
scores youtube just
a little more unfiltered so you don't
want to miss this
now let's get back to this copyright
debacle on sunday night i was browsing
twitter getting ready for a week full of
news
and i noticed one consistent theme
dmca strikes every single streamer
seemed to be tweeting about
them and multiple were reporting that
they themselves had been struck and i'm
going to get into
all of that and tell you exactly what's
going down on twitch right now
but first i've got to explain to you
what the hell a dmca strike
actually is prior to filming this video
i had a brief conversation with the
score's lawyer who
also happens to practice intellectual
property law and he was able to break
down what is a pretty complicated
situation now that said
nothing i'm telling you is actual legal
advice he was just able to clear up some
of my own confusion basically the dmca
or the digital millennium copyright act
was
put together in 1998 to protect creators
to make sure
people weren't taking their music or
their videos and using them without
their consent
and not compensating them as i'm sure
you know back then this whole internet
thing was
really taking off and they needed to put
some legislation in place to protect
creators when
literally all anyone was doing was
sharing files on the internet like
it was the napster era they needed to do
something to police this [ __ ]
what the dmca does is it lets somebody
who wrote a song or made a video to
identify
unfair use of that and then ask to be
compensated or have it taken down
that's what's happening here a bunch of
creators or the companies
that represent their ip rights are
saying hey
you guys can't use that without paying
us to a bunch of twitch streamers
all at once and to better understand the
situation we reached out to fighting
games caster and video games esports and
entertainment lawyer ultra david to get
his insight on the situation
years ago twitch just wasn't a big
enough deal and so rights holders just
didn't
care that much about it or didn't even
know about it i'm sure in many cases
obviously that has not been true for a
while now which has been a big deal
mainstream
wise for i don't know a few years at
this point it's not the case that twitch
has changed
uh over the last few years it's terms of
service with respect to music as far as
i know is unchanged what's different
now is that it seems like right soldiers
are being more aggressive
but yeah i think as far as why that is
happening now
and not seven years ago is just the
greater popularity of twitch more
knowledge of what's going on
on twitch among people who are in a
position to enforce their rights
when i talked about the you know twitch
in its early
few years not caring about this sort of
stuff
i think they were right they they
calculated they were willing to gamble
that they weren't going to get busted
because they were small enough and and
i think they figured well once we get
big enough you know we will
convert into taking copyright law more
seriously but
there's no reason for them to do that
unless the rights holders themselves are
being more aggressive
now when these strikes eventually
started to pile in
people understandably freaked the [ __ ]
out and started deleting all of their
vods and clips
because in the twitch terms of service
violating copyright can mean
a strike on your account and three
strikes you're out
that means your twitch count can be
deleted and for some people notably the
biggest names of the platform making a
ton of money
that could mean the end of their career
and yes this is all happening
even though people play music on stream
all the time even though it was the norm
for years
it has always more or less been illegal
what's maybe
most staggering about this situation is
the sheer volume of strikes we saw over
the weekend
and when i asked our lawyer about it it
led him to the hunch that it's possible
twitch has started to automate checking
for copyright infringement
much like youtube has been doing for
years or at the very least
one of these ip collectives that defends
creators
looked at twitch and said hey these guys
are pretty big you know
amazon we could maybe make some money
off them one report that i saw
said that the song in the club by 50
cent was one of the big offenders here
so maybe 50 decided that he was tired of
twitch streamers using his song
the bottom line here is that the way
that we experienced twitch
might have been changed forever i don't
think we're gonna be hearing a lot of
top 40 music in the next few weeks
okay so i know that was a lot about
copyright law but
i felt like i needed to get you up to
speed but what does this actually mean
for twitch
for streamers for me and you that are
watching well first your favorite
streamer
is probably not going to court and
they're definitely not kicked off twitch
yet so
don't worry about that and twitch
support has already tweeted
a statement regarding the situation they
said this week we've had a sudden influx
of dmca takedown requests for clips with
background music from 2017
to 2019. if you're unsure about rights
to audio in past streams
we advise removing those clips we know
many of you have large archives and
we're
working to make this easier this is the
first time we have received
mass dmca claims against clips we
understand this has been stressful and
affected creators and are working on
solutions
including examining how we can give you
more control over your clips
we adhere to the dmca which requires
that we take action on content and
streamer accounts
upon notice from rights holders as
happened this week our guidelines for
music have not changed
so please reference them here basically
that's twitch saying hey
we're just the platform in the dmca we
don't assume
any of the blame for any intellectual
property cases
so you guys should probably go and
delete your clips and so that's what's
happening
tons of streamers out there guys who
have streamed thousands and thousands of
hours
have gone back into their archive and
are starting to delete all their clips
and even some of their vods and that's
to say nothing of streamers that
literally rely on music to do their job
like djs or singers
for them this might be a little bit more
dire and the reality is
that everything i'm saying is based on
laws that are like 20 years old
the law just doesn't move very fast for
sure yeah the law is way way behind
there's no doubt about it in this
particular instance the issue
that twitch could ban people for is uh
is
is their infringement of copyright but
there's many ways that you could change
copyright laws so that what people are
doing
while streaming is not an infringement
of copyright
people watch streams not because of the
game necessarily right they may like
a game itself but in terms of say they
are a street fighter fan maybe they're
okay they're there for street fighter
but then there's any number of
who knows how many streams of people who
are streaming street fighter and they
choose one to watch
and why is that well they like the
player the player plays well
maybe it's a funny player maybe the
player's chat is good right whatever
community they've built is good
there there are reasons other than the
game itself
that they're interested in that streamer
and watching that stream
and that means that the streamer is
providing a lot so what i would really
like is
for that value to be recognized
by law i i want there to be some
probably limited but some degree
of right to be included in that sort of
stuff whether it's on twitch or youtube
or whatever it is
yeah i mean i i don't i don't know when
that will change i would really i really
hope it does
but it's hard for me to imagine there
being a
lobbying force that could counterbalance
disney what's more is it seems like this
might not be limited to just
vods and clips according to video games
ip and entertainment lawyer noah downs
on stream the other day
companies like warner have invested in
software that's able to detect
dmca violations live so that means one
of these strikes
could happen live in the future there's
a company out there that's monitoring
most streams on twitch and it's two
big investors um include
universal music group and um i
think one more i forget what the other
one is um well i think it might be
warner um it is warner and so universal
music group of warner have invested in
this company
that's monitoring every stream on twitch
and they have the ability to issue live
dmca's they just haven't done it yet
from where i'm sitting and the
information i've digested over the last
few days
this could actually get worse before it
gets better and honestly
i think it might be time for twitch to
step up to the plate a little here
as part of the dmca twitch as a platform
is required to
inform its creators about their
responsibilities when it comes to ip
stuff
that being said outside of a faq style
guidelines they don't really do much to
help you out
like if you're a 17 year old kid
starting on twitch how are you supposed
to know about any of this [ __ ] that's
kind of the difficulty with this legal
stuff
is that the law is 20 years old they had
no idea that in 20 years
people would be hopping on twitch and
playing fortnite with music
when they were 15. yeah i mean that
would be helpful i certainly think that
they could do more
part of why they don't do a a ton of
stuff is that
you know in order to abide by the idea
that they are
not liable for things that they're just
a passive platform they can't
well at least they're afraid of taking
too much affirmative
uh control in situations like this they
would much rather
seem as like look we're just providing
this space
it's not us hey we'll take on anything
that you
allege is infringing copyright we do
have these guidelines right we do have
here's the person that you uh contact in
case there is a copyright claim which is
one of the things that they're required
to do by law
but if if they were to be all about it
if they were to go you know very far in
the other direction of having a lot to
say constantly then i think their their
argument for being
uh for not being liable would be a
little tougher and for years this has
just been happening
thousands and thousands of hours of
people playing music with
very little ip punishment all that
happened was your vods got muted
and so here we are again much like the
inconsistent wardrobe policies and the
sometimes
random bannings twitch has left their
content creators in the dark
about this music situation for years and
obviously the streamers themselves are
to blame too
but there has to be some give and take
here this platform is making like
mega stars every month millions and
millions of dollars
the least they could do is tell that 17
year old kid trying to be the next ninja
that
maybe he shouldn't be playing drake's
latest song on stream
bro i'm the valent bug man like i've
been playing basically as much valerian
as i can
at all times here's the thing is i think
i'm a pretty bad aimer but dimitri was
saying this the other day that like
when i do things i get obsessed with
them so i just watch hiko stream and
like learn how to play
like macro sure